the calls are coming from inside the
house we've learned that the president's
daughter Ivanka Trump the one that Trump
would date if she weren't his daughter
remember that one she was in contact
with a Russian who offered to set up a
Trump Putin meeting and it was of course
not disclosed we have talked about how
Ivanka Trump's name has been sort of
noticeably missing from the Trump Russia
investigation how Robert Muller if
indeed he plans to talk to Ivanka Trump
seems to be waiting at least for now but
Ivanka Trump has now landed right in the
middle of the Donald Trump Michael Cohen
Russia fiasco so what we've learned is
that during the 2016 presidential
campaign and the timing is a key part of
this Ivanka Trump put Trump's personal
lawyer Michael Cohen in touch with the
Russian athlete named dmitriy klokov who
was offering to introduce Donald Trump
to Vladimir Putin specifically to work
on a hundred story
Trump Tower real estate project in
Moscow Russia
this has been confirmed by BuzzFeed
based on a review of email records that
they were shown but asked not to quote
directly and as of right now there's no
reason to think that this was an illegal
contact or that it was even a contact
related to the election it seems to have
been a business contact but it is very
relevant because it shows that even
while running for president Trump's
lawyer and daughter were considering
business deals in Russia which is
something that they have previously
denied and it's been really difficult to
get a comment from Ivanka about this
revelation but a spokesperson for Ivanka
Trump's lawyer that's as close as they
could get to get a comment they had to
go to Ivanka Trump's lawyer and be
referred to her lawyers spokesperson
said that Ivanka wasn't involved in the
project at all beyond simply reminding
Michael Cohen to tell her if anything
moves forward with Trump Tower Moscow
which it did not the problem is that the
emails reviewed by BuzzFeed suggest that
actually Ivanka was way more involved
than that for example in November of
2015
Ivanka told Michael Cohen specifically
go and speak to DES meet
klokov and then michael cohen did and
then it continued because after cohen
sent an email to klokov saying you know
what we don't actually need your help
with this project at all that's an email
on which Ivanka Trump was cc'd but hey
listen you can bcc'd on an email and not
be involved you can't control it if
someone else C sees you accept that
eventually Ivanka was further pulled
into it and actually went to Michael
Cohen and questioned him and said why
are you refusing to deal with dmitriy
klokov that's not exactly just saying
let me know if it pans out and then
never getting involved in it again so
once again this is the trend when you
lie to the press about your involvement
it suggests that there's more to look
into we've learned that Michael I'm
sorry that Robert Muller is aware of
this and is potentially exploring this
Avenue she claims her involvement was
essentially zero but she was actually
more involved than zero and once again
it went from nobody anywhere had contact
with Russians that became there might
have been incidental contact to any
contact that there was was an illegal -
even if it was a legal trumple part and
everybody incur including himself
and there's actually a movement if
sometimes you have to step back to
understand sort of the big picture of
what's going on on the one hand we have
this news about Ivanka Trump's
connection to Russia on the other hand
you're starting to see increasingly
people on the right talk about it would
be totally inappropriate for a Vanka
Trump to be pulled into Robert Moeller's
investigation Rudy Giuliani was recently
talking about it on Fox News with sean
hannity saying it would just be stepping
over some imaginary line if Ivanka Trump
gets called in by Robert Muller
it seems like they're preparing for
Ivanka Trump to get called in by Robert
Muller
yeah I like that Jared Kushner is
replaceable but don't go after Ivanka I
mean this could blow over it could all
be nothing's right if we know anything
about the Trump business and the Trump
campaign it's very family connected so
if Don jr. is implicated in the rush of
stuff if Jared Kushner is implicated in
the Russia stuff it stands to reason
that Ivanka could be as well and it also
stands to reason that Trump knew about
what was going on who believes that
Trump was being kept in the dark about
all of this stuff and whether it's the
Trump Tower meeting or whatever else the
timing of
Trump's tweets and comments it all
suggests that he knew he knew what was
going on and he was being kept up to
speed on that stuff and maybe maybe
someday we'll actually find out the full
truth of it you can discuss this story
or any others that interest you on the
david pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our IDI di t quick
break part two of my interview with eric
Turk himer coming up next today's
program is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses which I now have
two pairs of Warby Parker offers a free
five day in-home trial of their glasses
you try five pairs you see which you
like I wear contact lenses on the show
but I often wear glasses at night and on
weekends and both of my pairs of Warby
Parker glasses are great I did the free
at-home trial
I picked five frames that I liked on
their website they sent them to me I
picked the one I liked the most sent
them back typed in my prescription
online and soon I got my finished
glasses with my prescription in the mail
and I love this because when I'm at a
glasses store trying on glasses I can't
really figure out if I like them because
I feel the pressure of the salespersons
gaze on me I want to show the glasses to
other people I need time to figure out
which glasses I want to commit to and
the eyeglass industry is also controlled
by a tiny number of companies which
keeps prices very high I even know
people who have spent over three hundred
dollars for a pair of glasses but with
Warby Parker there start at just 95
dollars that's what mine cost to try the
five pairs and support the David Pakman
show go to war V Parker trial comm /t
DPS